debout j'ai beaucoup travaillé
wall street est ce que votre appareil un
meuble a lancé dans un niveau stable au
sénat montrera plus je ne suis pas mort
et que le réalisme non plus elle puisque
réalisme il ya c'est l'histoire morale
et physique de mon atelier
c'est la société dans son eau dans le
sont pas dans son milieu
c'est au nom de qui vient c'est fun mais
c'est moi alors à leur poids discutant
proches ce que j'entends et mauvais en
veille
[Musique]
ils veulent faire comme les livres et
les pavillons du réalisme
excusez moi mademoiselle mais la femme
n'est pas seulement autre que l'homme
ait la moindre son sexe constitue une
faculté en moins là où la virilité
montrent le sujet est avec vous vous
croyez qu'il ya des droits pour l'un qui
ne soient pas des droits pour l'autre ce
que l'être humain est un être humain au
féminin comme au masculin
qu'est ce que tu veux à la fin obtenir
l'affranchissement si tu étais pas oui
eh ben c'est pas le sujet